I'm excited to open up our talk today
and to introduce you to two incredible
leaders and let's start with this.
How do real people succeed
in the real world of work?
Kind of a loaded question, but how do
they do it? What is their secret sauce?
That's the question that bestselling
author Joanna Barsh sets out to answer,
but not by talking to well established
CEOs or motivational gurus.
Instead,
she dives into the trenches with some
of today's brightest and boldest up and
coming leaders with 30 years over 30
years at Mckinsey and Company and three
bucks to her name.
We really have a lot to learn from Joanna.
She's here to distill the stories of over
200 rising leaders from 120 companies
around the globe,
all with the aim to help millennials grow
through the challenges we face at work.
We're also joined by Amy Yuri,
who was a 15 year veteran of Google and
I sell multiple leadership roles on the
advertising side of the business.
Amy currently oversee developing
video ad products for Google marketing
solutions globally.
She is also a founding member of the women
at Google Leadership Board and hosted
Joanna back in 2012 at one of the first
women at Google leadership summits.
Without further ado, I'm going to bring
Joanna and Amy up to the stage. Um,
Joanna is going to dig into some of
the key learnings from her recent book
before being joined by
Amy for a fireside chat.
I just ask that you make sure
you're sitting next to someone.
I'm as there's an activity
that will take place, um,
during Joanna's talk and it's
important that you've got a buddy. Um,
and without further ado,
let's give Joanna a warm welcome.
Well thank you.
And I could see the gentleman over there.
You sit next to that Nice Lady, right?
Right. Uh, one and I'm, I'm here.
Yeah, yeah. You're sitting by
yourself, just squeegee over,
which is a technical term for sitting
next to somebody and the two of you are
like back to back, front to back. Now
you should sit on this, sit together.
Come on it. This won't be
painful and it won't take much,
much time cause I've only
been given 10 to 15 minutes.
So I'm going to talk
like a New Yorker really,
really quickly and see if I can
get you curious about yourself,
about the challenges that you're
facing at work. And you know,
maybe we can have a conversation
about that very, very shortly.
So let's start with the first risk, which
is you, you're here. You took a risk,
today was a big day in New York and we're
proving that terrorism is nothing to
New Yorkers.
So we've already jumped off a cliff.
What does it feel like?
What about your work?
Think about the risks that you could be
taking at work and you may be thinking
about or avoiding.
So what risk are you taking today given
that the subways are now working again?
So that's no longer a risk that you
couldn't get here. Think about it. Uh,
during this talk,
I started out in 2015 after 30
something years as Taylor said it,
Mckinsey, to actually talk to younger
people. Why? Because, you know,
it's really awful talking
to CEOs who have made it.
They have their stories,
men and women alike,
and they've been media trained and so
it's very hard to actually get to know
them. Younger people don't have their
stories finished yet. It's very exciting.
Like you don't know how it's gonna
turn out after you've interviewed them.
So I thought it was a feminist idea.
I reached out to a
hundred or so companies.
There are about 15 startups in the group.
There are also individuals who
are actors, artists, scientists,
not your norm, lawyers, doctors,
not your normal big company employees.
Every single one of these people was
considered by the person that recommended
them to be high performing high potential.
So that's the base.
And also talked to another of
55 HR professionals about them,
which was very enjoyable. And we'll see
what came out of that and in a moment.
And I basically said,
what defines you?
Let's talk about your childhood and how
you grew up and what you think of now.
What's coming to you now. It's kind
of a deep psychological interview,
which worked pretty and it's got some
interesting things out about people.
And then I asked them about what is a
high point at work or a low point at work
in the last year. And it just
collected those and got those stories,
which are amazing. Oh,
ah. I also asked people,
what do you think about millennials?
And I got an ear full.
What do you think about
women? Interesting. Why did,
we could talk about that later.
Why asked that question?
What do you think about women?
And I meant it in a truly collegial
way and what do you think about work?
So we have a whole battery of what
millennials think and it is mythbusting.
But first the weird thing happened
that this group of people,
which I had not thought about,
turns out to be the most diverse group
of people ever that I think have appeared
in a book.
So they're from all over the world.
Are People working in the u s
from 80 different countries?
I'm sure in this room we have a similar
dispersion of where people come from.
And what experiences you've had in life
already. And that's part of diversity.
They also, I met, uh, married
people, single people,
single people with children,
married people with children. People
work in every function. You can imagine.
People who didn't go to college, people
went to premier colleges. You name men.
I met those people.
So that to me says we've got an
interest in pool of experiences.
What can we learn from them? Well,
here's the first thing we learn.
Uh, a lot of people make their living off
of talking about millennials. I do not,
first of all, I don't really make
a living anymore. But secondly,
when I talked to people,
I generally talk about leadership.
So you probably recognize these words
that people talk about when they talk
about millennials. Uh, my favorite
being the trophy hunter. Uh,
but as one millennial told me,
hmm, let's just think about lazy.
I'm sure in the baby boomer generation,
there are plenty of lazy people as well.
So before we cast a dispersion
on millennials, let's
look at every generation.
So I did, and this is what
I learned as well about uh,
older people,
myself included.
And you know I like the slow because I
am a little bit slower these days at 64.
But nonetheless,
this is complete bullshit.
So you already knew that I haven't
touched you anything new yet,
so I'm going to keep going. This
is what they told me. To me,
if you think about your life in
these terms, it's pretty scary,
right?
You're at a place and you've just made
a mistake and you know that mistakes are
not an option here or that
you wake up every day and say,
I don't even know I'm working here
because work has no passion for me.
And everybody says I should have passion.
What about pressure?
You all have deadlines. Pressure is
the kind of thing that destroys health.
It boils over and then you
lose sight of what it is.
It's really important to you.
What if you are working with bullies
and Villian villains, and I have,
I wrote tough characters, but come on
for the record. We know who they are,
they're assholes.
What are you working for them?
What if everybody says you have to have
a sponsor and you know in your heart
there is no sponsor and and the people
around you and you don't know how to get
one. You're not even sure you want
one. You just got a bad review,
literally whack you over the head and
then the person giving you the reus says,
well what do you, what do you
think about that? It's like, what?
What do I think about that? Then you're
given an assignment, you're a superhero,
you feel really good about yourself and
it turns out it's mission impossible and
nobody's ever succeeded doing that before.
But you've got the job and
my favorite of all favorites,
you wake up and everything sucks.
What does everything sucks.
That's a military term by the way.
It comes from the army.
What this means is that
your job is going badly.
Your relationship just exploded.
You have been gaining weight at a
steady pace as your badly eating's since
you're not sleeping enough and then
finally even your mother calls you up to
yell at you, right? So everything
sucks. In that scenario.
And then the final chapter
of this book is worth work.
Just as if you have passion but not
for this work doesn't feel worth it.
What do you do? Do you go or do you
stay? Do you wait it out or not?
So those are all the challenges
that are in this book.
And every story in this book is if
you would instant experience for you.
So you don't need to be 64 years old and
thinking about your whole life deeply
as the other training that I do for
Google. You can just read the story.
So I give you the story of Greg.
Let's meet Greg. He's a sports writer.
He has a dream job writing
for a famous magazine.
He's what a he. He likes to
call a bro. So Greg's Bro,
very bright one, and Lo and
behold, six months into his job,
his father is hospitalized with a
failing heart and probably will die.
So Greg quits his job.
Doesn't mean, think about it.
He moves into the hospital to help
his father run his finance business.
The father needs a heart,
but he is not very high up on the
donor list and time is running out.
So what does Greg do?
Greg says,
I'm going to find out about donations
and see if I can solve this issue.
And that's what he did.
He got into it and then he realizes the
entire industry of donations is an old
boys' club.
None of the CEOs of any
of these businesses want
anything to do with Greg was a
26 year old guy.
He says he looks like he's 12 so
he doesn't have a lot of Gravitas.
Um,
but he comes out of this situation.
There is good news here and
I'll get to it in a minute.
He comes out of this situation,
able to change his job,
help his father and start a new business,
which we'll talk about.
But before I get to the
punchline of that story,
one of the tools that
comes out of this chapter,
which is bringing others on board is
something that I learned from Greg.
And so I want to, I want to
test it out on you. Is it?
Are you okay being Guinea pigs for
like the next two minutes? Okay.
The guy in the back says fine,
so the rest of you please come along.
Here's what we're going to do.
Pair up and if you're a trio then one
of you can be the observer and just sort
of Doctor Freud like just sit there
like this. During the next two minutes,
one of you will be a speaker, one of
you will be a listener and if again,
as I said,
you don't want to do this exercise
listening to somebody who's doing it,
you'll learn a lot speakers,
you know who you are.
You are the one who's willing to talk
to the guy or lady next to you about
something that seriously
is important to you.
It probably is bothering you right now,
so you're going to get two
minutes of free coaching listener.
There is only one thing you have
to do, which is listen. Okay,
that's it. Everybody ready
you? You got your pears go.
I should hear noise now.
It
sure.
Okay.
Who amongst the listeners
said something spoke,
said anything like,
ah yeah that happened to me or yeah.
How did it feel to listen without
saying anything to anybody?
Succeed. Succeed in the, in the two
minutes she did. So what did it feel like?
Just shout it out.
It feels like
relating to their advice.
It's hard not to say something.
That's interesting.
Did anybody who was among the speakers,
did you find,
what did you, what did you find speaking
for two minutes, having the floor.
Does anybody have the floor for
the whole two minutes? Yeah.
What did it feel like? Weird. I love that.
Weird. It felt weird. What was weird
about it? There was no response. Yeah.
Yeah. It's like, it's very
hard to talk for two minutes,
but did anybody have a
different experience too?
You got to talk for two minutes
and I have a lot to say. Yes.
Yeah.
Isn't it wonderful that somebody is
listening for do friggin minutes?
You felt the same way
and have somebody hear you and see you?
So I have done this experiment,
uh,
last week in Dubai and I found that
half the room thought it was weird and
really hard to fill two minutes and
the other half thought it was like 10
seconds. It just flew by. So
there's a right answer here,
but the act of listening is the most
powerful leadership skill you can develop.
So if you have a team and you
truly can listen with your heart,
not from our normal stance of listening,
which is I wonder if that
person's right or wrong.
I wonder if I'm learning
something I didn't already know.
What I'm going to say to that
person is where you stop listening.
The minute you use the voice in your
head starts, you are no longer listening.
Even if you think you are.
So learning to just
listen from their stance,
not from yours is a huge skill.
So that's,
that's the tool. What,
what happens to Greg? Well,
you notice the Greg is
no longer a sportswriter.
He is now a founder
and CEO of a nonprofit,
which is called organize of
course, right? Organs donating,
organize.
There you go.
And it turns out as Greg's dad was on
the way to the hospital with his wife to
have an end of life counseling session,
a 26 year old in Massachusetts,
died in a car accident
or a motorcycle accident.
And while he was HPV positive, his
heart was in good shape. And therefore,
uh, Greg's father was the next
person on the list at this hospital,
got the heart and survived,
which is pretty amazing.
But that's actually not the story.
The story is that Greg learned as he
started up organize to listen and stop
selling his ideas.
And he shifted from telling
people to asking people.
And that made all the difference
to the donors that came on board.
What he learned is that if you actually
engage people with the problem,
I have this really hard problem I'm
trying to solve. Can you help me?
People's brains get engaged so fast they
can't stop thinking about your problem.
And now they're on board and it
turns out the money is the easy part.
So that is what Greg learned.
And he managed to bring a guy named Al
Roth onboard who won a Nobel prize for a
designing markets. He teach, he was
teaching at the time at Harvard.
He's now somewhere else. I don't,
I haven't tracked him down,
but this is a very cool story to bring
someone like that on board to a startup.
So Greg learned that,
that lesson.
So now you've got listing
and you've got to asking,
but what else could you do if bringing
people on board is your challenge of the
day.
Start with your intention started.
You go into a meeting or you go
talk to members of your team.
What is it you really want to create?
If you have that squared away,
then everything will
fit into that framework.
It's most of us don't start with that.
Most of us just start with,
I'm just here and let's see what happens.
Stand in the other person's shoes,
which you know how to do.
The hard part is to to let go of judgment.
We always stand in their shoes and then
we judge them because we're human beings.
Everybody does that.
But if you can learn to stop judging
and get curious about that person,
you will actually create a
connection that is very strong. You,
you don't have to love them,
you just have to try to understand them,
listen from their center,
not your own center and
ask really good questions.
A good question is a question
that doesn't just have a yes,
no answer.
Free often does not start with the
word why and opens up possibilities for
solutions.
So what are you trying to create is a
great question to somebody who you might
be having a conflict with. Tell me more
about what you're trying to create.
Be present, not dominant. What does that
mean? Well we know a dominant means.
It means like I am the smartest person
in the room so I'm just going to keep
talking and being present means I'm
alert and focus and here with you,
which is better if you want to
connect to people, it's pretty clear.
Being present is going to get you a lot
more connections then big dominant and
the final to do is to
use silence as a tool.
Silence is really uncomfortable.
It is also weird and all of us fill it.
If you learn to not fill it,
the good thing is somebody on your team
will fill it and they might tell you
something you didn't know or
have a really, really good idea.
So practice silence.
And if someones asks you a
question in a big meeting,
you silence it will cause everybody
to listen harder if you use it.
So those are my thoughts. We, I was
told it's t did we do 10 minutes?
Come on up Amy, because at this point
I am becoming dominant, not present.
So
I give it to you please.
Uh, everybody gives Joanna.
Oh actually I want to go one more
Diogo you'll help me one more.
So this is the big,
so what Amy went through training
and centered leadership. Uh, with me,
I was really,
really honored to have people from Google
as part of our training when I was at
a Mckinsey and shaping it.
This is the big, so what?
You're an iceberg.
We all see what you say and what you do,
what you don't say, what you don't do.
That's what we see. That's all we see.
And that's what we judge.
And you are so much more than that.
Underneath that is everything
you're thinking and feeling
and you're never going
to disclose.
And underneath that is your really,
uh, thinking about what matters to you,
what you believe, what your values are.
Sometimes you don't even know what's,
that's what's driving your behavior.
And underneath that is your human needs.
Often people talk about it as fear,
but actually it's what is your deepest,
deepest need as a human being.
And that is what drives all of the
behavior, everything that's down there.
So you start to think of yourself
in that way without judgment,
you're going to learn a lot. And as you
read through other people's stories,
you can put yourself in them
and accelerate your own growth.
That's what I had to say.
Thank you.
Yeah, no. Um, it's, it's an honor
to have you back at Google and, uh,
and yes,
I do remember many of these exercises as
part of the central leadership program.
Um,
and specifically some of
the young childhood memory,
um,
exercises where you asked us to look back
and talk about experiences that shaped
us. Um, so, uh, it's,
it's an honor to have you back and thank
you for coming off of a trip from Dubai.
Um, Joanna has been traveling
around the world talking about, uh,
this book and obviously centered
leadership. Um, and you mentioned,
uh, you know, that your first book,
uh, how remarkable women lead, um,
was focused on what you'd call
the more experienced works at.
So what drove you to say,
all right,
maybe I shouldn't gain new perspective.
What,
what created that sense of curiosity
for you? Show it and action
started with this young ladies in
the room, um, in the front row.
Who doesn't work at Google? Well, my, um,
she said, I think your
a book is boring. Um,
and she was my, she's my daughter. She's
allowed to say that. And so it's actually,
it's really okay. And W I asked her what
she meant and she said, they're so old,
the, these leaders, I can't be them,
I'm not even sure I want to be them.
And so how do I get there from
here is, is a mystery to me. Uh,
and I began to think about, well,
what about people under the age of 40,
what w w what is happening to them?
And is it different today than
it was 40 years ago? I mean,
some of the people I interviewed were 80,
and you know,
I was like on the edge of my seat to
make sure they made it through the
interview.
They were amazing people,
but they lived in a different
environment and a different situation.
And today, uh, I'm impressed.
I'm in awe of millennials.
So I thought it would be really cool
as I was retiring from Mckinsey, uh,
to hang out with a bunch of people who
actually had a lot of hope for life.
And was it, it was, it wasn't.
I'm still interviewing people,
so if anybody wants to be interviewed,
just let me know. In fact,
somebody in this room was interviewed,
but I'm not going to tell you who it
is because everybody's confidential.
Um,
so what did you,
what was the epiphany for you in terms
of what red would resonate in the way
that it changed the way you wrote this
book? I, I've obviously read both and,
and the style,
how remarkable women lead versus
the story is a little bit different.
Can you talk about what changed that?
So a one interviewee said,
I'm through with school,
I just don't need to be taught anymore.
And adults learn by doing.
And uh, the adults that I'm trying
to reach for everybody in this room,
you don't have that much experience.
You might have six years,
10 years of experience and a jor
experience has really important.
But wouldn't it be really cool to have
like infinite experience of all these
other people who face the
challenge that you're now facing,
but they did it differently than you.
So at least they'll give you
something to think about.
So that's what I wanted to do. I want
it to collect the tapestry of stories.
Now the Internet is full of people with
stories and I started to look at them
and they're fake.
It's like Susan had an issue.
And then it gives you like one paragraph
and then in the second paragraph she
solves the issue and gets promoted.
So or she doesn't solve the issue.
And then the author says,
[inaudible] it had Susan only
asked a question she would have,
you know,
whatever gotten the brass ring.
So I wanted to write stories
that you would go like,
what's really going to happen?
And the answer is I don't know,
because they haven't lived their whole
life yet. Will that person becomes famous?
I don't know. But there, to me,
they became very, very interesting.
The second thing I wanted
to do is make it real.
And you could argue with me that it's
not real enough for you and that may
indeed be the truth. But I
didn't want to sort of say, Amy,
just I want to leave you with thinking
about why you're so uncomfortable about
that question. Instead say, Amy,
why don't you go meet that person over
there and have a discussion about what
gets them excited?
That's something you could actually
do as opposed to go home and go,
what did she say? So that, that
was my goal. You, you did a, um,
something at the end of every chapter
as well to try to give kind of a toolkit
for folks to think about how
to solve the challenge. Um,
how did you think about creating the
different solutions that you did and,
and is there any order in which
you could go through and, uh,
solving these, these work
challenges? And, you know,
every buddies challenge is different.
And I became quite humble.
I don't,
could only put in the original book had
it was like 400 pages and it had 120
stories in it. And now it's 75 stories
and you may still find it too long.
But nonetheless, I went through
all the stories, bottoms up,
kind of like a Google data
mining exercise. So though
I was an English major,
I apologize. And uh, and I, uh,
found what these people did.
And then through my own experience of
centered leadership and being at Mckinsey
and Bain consultant and on and on,
I put them into a structure,
which is first one, a CEO once said
to me, just tell me what to do first,
second,
third in that order.
So I tried to order the actions at the
end of each chapter based on if you don't
know where you are, start at the
top and have you already done that.
Go to the place where it's
now news for you. Great.
Um, I know that I am managing people.
People always say, well, okay,
well where do I start?
How do I do this?
So I appreciate you giving
that specific advice. Um,
I love that the titles of the
challenges, um, and you know,
you went through all of
them upfront. Uh, you know,
some of them definitely probably
hit closer to home for Googlers. Um,
including, uh, the, what do
you do after a poor review?
Because we just had our,
uh, peripheral view cycle,
so everybody's just got their annual
feedback and might still be digesting and
thinking, okay, not what it,
what do I do next? Um, uh,
I also love, uh, you know, the, the,
some of the titles including when you
have to be a superhero because you know,
working for a company like Google, I
know people feel like, you know, the,
the bar keeps moving higher and
the task keeps getting bigger.
And to your point, I have to
solve a problem that nobody's
ever solved before. Um,
uh, I personally love when a risk taking
feels like jumping off a cliff. Um,
and for some of us we either enjoy
jumping off cliffs where or are afraid of
heights. Um, what is your
favorite challenge in the book?
When I woke up this morning,
I,
for some reason I was thinking because
of that jump off the cliff of cliff
divers, which I woke up with
like, oh, a semi heart attack.
I don't want to do that.
So my favorite chapters to actually win
everything socks because the came from a
military story of a woman who
had been to Afghanistan. And uh,
she taught me some things that I
had really never thought about it.
I don't know if anybody has
military experience in the room,
but it's completely different
than anything in life.
So I put her in the book for
that reason. Uh, ended. Um,
there were other people where
everything sucks. For example,
a woman who started up a really cool
business with her friends from her prior
work and uh,
she was kicked out by those friends and
on her own one June morning and had to
restart herself.
So there are all kinds of situations
where you find a man who worked in an
automotive company, uh, who, um,
his marriage started falling apart.
He was working on the most exciting thing,
renewable energy in cars.
He was totally committed to this.
And then they shut his project down,
which I'm sure happens at Google,
you know, once in a while.
And he just imploded. And
somebody said to him, he didn't.
One day you'll tell your grandchildren
about this project. And he was thinking,
I don't have a job be,
I'm not gonna have any grandchildren.
So he had to pull himself together. So
why, that's why I liked that, the chapter.
But what it does is it helps you prepare
for something that hopefully you'll
never be in, but I'm sure you will
cause, um, work ends up, you know,
after a great week, the next week,
it sucks and you didn't ask for it.
And the first thing you do to
prepare is, uh, to be mentally,
physically, emotionally and spiritually
resilient, which I hadn't thought about,
which is why the military forces
people to go through physical training.
That's awful because you develop stamina
and resistance and alertness in the
midst of the unexpected.
So resilience, curiosity, bravery.
What are,
what are some of these attributes that
if you look at the collection of stories
and the people that you've seen,
obviously their stories are not complete,
but what are some of the
attributes that you've seen, um,
are common amongst those that have learned
how to overcome challenges and even
reframe challenges as
opportunities? The, so people, uh,
you know, we, you remember that
first slide was stereotypes.
People think of millennials is waiting
for someone to hand them the answer.
And I didn't find that at all.
I found the strongest element
to be curiosity and bravery.
So a challenge is something you
really don't want to face, uh,
because you know, it's not going to be
fun and it might actually be painful.
Um,
and yet the people who faced
these challenges did so
because they were driven by
a desire to grow. Uh, and some
of them were driven by fear.
So a fear that if they didn't grow,
they would fall behind.
And in this generation,
if there's one theme that I didn't know,
I would find it is that, uh, you're, you,
you are growing up with uncertainty.
Um, and when I grew up, uh,
in, in the 50s, it was like
fake on Sir. Fakes are empty,
but it was certain,
you know,
you lived in a house and your dad came
home at night and you never saw him,
but you knew he was working and
everything was cool and you played.
And that was your job just to
play every day. Whereas today,
I think people from the Internet,
from being global citizens of the world,
from having, you know, parents
who've lost their jobs, you,
you grew up with uncertainty.
And that means that you gotta be growing
wherever you work because you're in
charge of you.
You already know that.
Now it's up to older people who manage
you to realize that that's what's driving
you.
And once you're an owner of your future,
then you basically measure
everything in terms of am I growing?
And challenges are the best way to grow.
So the people in this book,
they didn't all succeed, but they
all sort of took the challenge on,
um, in, uh, in looking at the,
at the stories of people, um, and
those that are continuously growing.
Did you find any differences in terms
of the stories from men or women?
So I counter programmed the
book, uh, because there, um,
there was no theme that I found,
maybe you could prove me wrong,
uh, but, uh, men told me that women
were more aggressive, more driven,
more goal driven.
Uh,
we're really kicking ass and women
told me that men were more courageous,
willing to take a chance and
kicking ass. So, you know, it was,
and there are all kinds of people in the
book. So I put in men who were afraid,
men who made mistakes and
had to live through it. Uh,
and I put in women who are
totally, uh, you know, bold,
aggressive because that's what I heard.
And then I,
and then I put the opposite in as
well. So there are, for example,
a quiet people in the book were
very introverted and still heroes.
And then there are a noisy,
noisy people in the book too,
who are very outgoing and able to
lead through their social skills.
So I have a couple of more questions,
but I wanna give you guys a chance
to ask Joanna some questions, uh,
about centered leadership, about women's
leadership, about grow or you work, uh,
about life challenges, uh, uh, about, uh,
bringing your daughter
with you along the journey.
And so on that I just will ask one more
question and turn it over to you guys.
Um, you know, what do you hope, obviously
you, you've mentioned, um, you know,
Gabby and she's part of the
trove, this of this in terms of the
impetus for, for writing this book. Um,
what beyond, um, you're on family.
What do you hope people will take
away from this book? I, I, um,
I'm passing the baton, so I'm,
I'm 64 years old. I worked my,
not my whole life.
I worked in the movie business and some
other things before a Mckinsey. Uh,
but you were the future. Uh,
millennials are our future.
So my hope is that this book accelerates
enough people to take on challenges
and, uh, and become leaders
at very early ages. Um,
and maybe you already are all leaders
who are in this room or, and by leader,
I don't mean somebody who runs
like a company with a million app,
employees leader meaning somebody who
sees something and makes it happen because
you believe it should happen.
It should be the way reality is.
Um, a person with vision,
a person with a drive,
some kind of purpose. And if you
don't have any of that right now,
I hope this book will help you on your
journey to find it because it took me 50
years to realize that meaning is for
me the most important thing in life.
Uh, and it's sort of beats all else
clearly loving having friends you love,
having family love, um, helps you
along that journey. But I discovered,
at least for me,
that it wasn't enough that you needed
to be able to help people be part of
something bigger than you
and that that's what this is.
I want you to take action based on
the challenges that you're facing.
That's what I want.
I'm going to turn it over to you guys.
If you have a a couple of questions,
they're stupefied
God kick us off.
So that, yeah, in the B
dangerous question to take us off track a
little bit, but I, I, I'm dying to know.
How would you think about the challenges
that you framed in the book for
millennials compared to Gen x and,
uh,
does it matter if you're in
the gen x working at Google?
Um, what, what, what do you, how do you
see that dividing over for, you know,
just kidding. I'm worrying
about that chapter. Yeah.
And um,
there are a couple of you in the room
who may consider yourselves more gen x
then,
um,
millennial gen x ers told me that they
were raised to suck it up until they
reached the goal that
they wanted. That, uh,
for some reason they felt the loyalty
of the company that if they were to wait
it out and gain the skills that they
would get where they wanted to go.
And millennials basically said, I'm out
of time. I can't wait that long. In fact,
maybe I can wait a year.
So that's the, to me,
that was the fundamental difference
between the two. If you, you know, and an,
and as Sheryl Sandberg Admonish
me, uh, just a few weeks ago,
never say all because it's
not true of all people.
It's always true of some
people but not all people.
So genexers I think can
learn a lot from millennials,
which is what are you waiting
for? Do it now as, take the risk.
Now ask the question now. And if
somebody says no, they say no,
you will have learned from the experience.
And I said something a few minutes
ago that a lot of the people,
the book took on challenges and quote
unquote did not succeed in the normal
scheme of things.
Right?
They didn't get the promotion or the gold
ring or whatever you were hoping they
would get, but they learned
something. So in that sense,
they succeeded through every
challenge that they met.
There was a story of a woman
who got a bad review. Actually.
It was a pretty good review. She worked
for a tech company, not yours. And, uh,
she, uh, was an African woman set
very high standards for herself.
And so she didn't like the review she
got and people didn't like her apparently
that was in the review
as well, that, you know,
she's pushy and she set the bar high
and she couldn't stand mediocrity.
Does this sound familiar? And everybody
around her was mediocre and her mind.
So she quit and I had the
conversation with her.
I'm sure that company was sad
that she quit, but she said, I,
this is not the culture
I want to be a part of.
I don't want to fit in and have harmony.
I like reaching for perfection.
And so the only thing
that saddened me with her,
and I call her EFA in the book,
If you read the book,
is that she was striving for perfection
because she felt she had to make it.
It's one thing to strive for
perfection because it motivates you.
It's another thing to actually think you
have to achieve perfection because that
ain't gonna happen. So in
that sense, if it made me sad,
but I kept in touch with her,
she ended up in a startup and
she's really happy doing, you know,
striving for perfection and creating
software that the world needs.
So you just said the differences act
now versus a wait a little bit later and
one of the, well the first
chapter hit me personally, uh,
because uh,
I just lost a longtime colleague who said,
I just have,
I don't have passion in what
I'm doing here any longer. Um,
and you mentioned in the book
though that you say, you know,
as part of the toolkit, maybe wait a
year before you actually make a move.
So how do you think about the, there's
a lot you can do in that year. Yeah,
I mean so do you,
I mean cause you're saying millennials
want to act now and you are giving more
that invite advice that I would say is,
you know,
take a little bit of time before you
make, just make that, um, act action.
And that was the same advice I gave her.
I said,
just stick it out for
another couple of months.
Try to do this with your job
differently. Do this. And, and she just,
she came back to me after, uh, taking a
little short leave and just said, I can't,
I just, I, I, I'm no longer my heads nod.
My head and heart are no longer in this.
First of all, the good news is you may
have lost her, but the world didn't lose.
No, I know. And I'm helping. I'm helping
her find something else. So, so, so, uh,
let me rephrase.
Um,
she was probably pretty busy while those
few months were going by in which she
was meditating on her decision.
So let's say you're in a job you don't
want to be in, and I'm telling you, uh,
maybe you should wait a year
because it's a brand new job.
You will not have seen the whole business
cycle if you leave in three months.
Because if it's a really bad fit, you'll
know it and you should leave right away.
If in fact, you just uncomfortable,
you're not learning fast enough,
you feel sadness, then what are you do?
Well, you talked to a lot of people,
so you take that time to learn
as you go learn something else,
do something outside of work
that expands your horizons.
So don't wait as in, okay, I guess.
So cycle starts in five hours.
So I guess I'll just hang out here and
go there tonight and see if I can pick my
spirits up instead.
You really just network like crazy.
You're introverted.
Absolutely network like crazy and
go ask people what their jobs are.
Learn how to do to ask your boss.
I want to do more.
I'm bored to tears for God's sakes.
Amy gimme something else to do and Amy
will dream it up and give it to you and
you and you won't get paid more, but you
will love learn. So during that year,
be busy growing and there are very
concrete things you can do to do that.
I see this gentleman.
Yeah, patient as can be.
Thank you for coming the
bunking millennials yet again.
Got It. Quick question
for either one of you. Um,
if you guys have a story or anecdote
from kind of early on in your careers.
The first time that you maybe did have
this impactful leader and kind of maybe
what it looks like to you or how it
did influence your kind of career going
forward.
Take it away. Um, the question is,
did I have an impactful leader?
Yeah. Early on in your career, was
there anybody that stood out and really,
you kind of recognized, oh,
this is a, you know, um,
an obvious great leader and there,
or really bad and they're helping
me in this way, or, you know,
kind of push you to, to do something,
maybe challenge you in some way.
Okay. Um, so, yes, on both sides,
right? Um, those that were not as, um,
those that you don't admire and you
observe very carefully for all the things
that you make along mental list of the
things that you'll never do when you're a
manager. Um, and then, um,
I love, um, actually, um,
I lean notten is somebody that
endorsed, um, Joanna as buck.
And I lean started in the New York
office long time ago when I was here.
And she sat,
uh,
one cube away from me and became somebody
that I helped her figure out how to,
uh, navigate Google because
she'd come from timing. And, um,
so I helped her figure out Google. She
helped me then learn a lot about, uh,
leadership, women's
leadership and we became, um,
a longtime friends.
She's obviously gone on to be a
mini different roles within Google,
um, and most recently is now our
head of people operations. Um,
and I had the opportunity to see her
last week. Um, and one of the things,
uh, she, she had this,
did a talk on leadership a long
time ago and um, you know, she said,
be a snob for talent,
meaning higher are really amazing people,
people that are better from you.
That was one of the things. And, um,
and she also gave me a lot
of permission early on to,
um,
to not always be thinking about
vertically climbing,
but the importance of horizontal and as
Cheryl Wofford's to edge climbing the
jumbled jungle gym to kind of,
you know,
have lots of different experiences and
having somebody like her who had done
that in her career, she's moved and
now you see, even within Google, um,
to lots of different roles
and functions kind of gave me
permission to think about doing the same.
Sometimes villains can actually
teach you as much as great leaders.
So early in my career I
worked in retail and uh,
there was a woman who was my height,
which means that she was height
challenged and Mrs Wilner,
uh, and she, uh, tour people
down. She actually enjoyed it.
So I think she was on the spectrum of
a sociopath close to close to the edge.
And I developed, I'm a bloody nose.
I would come, uh, unpredictably,
I was running some shops in a retailer
and I did all kinds of cool things in
those shops to get people to actually
stop and buy things. Or even just look.
So I had everything up ended and looked
all like it would fall apart in a second.
And she took the whole team to the
shop and in front of all the customers
screamed at me till I was in tears.
So that was my earliest
memory of uh, what, uh,
it's really like to work for a villain.
Um,
and so I switched retailers and I ended
up with a taller blonder version of the
same woman and worked for
her. And, uh, she, uh,
did similar things that taught me.
Uh,
essentially if the doesn't
want you to succeed,
there are a billion things that you have
to get right into your job and you will
get something wrong and they will find it.
So I learned that I couldn't be perfect.
Uh,
that it was really embarrassing when I
had a bloody nose in front of customers.
Uh, and, uh,
it gave me the impetus to go to business
school and completely changed my career.
So I went from retail to consulting
where people, only clients yelled at me,
Oh, got a lot better,
another improvement part.
Another important lesson that I give, uh,
and, and have tried to follow, which is,
you know, once you work for
a terrible boss, you kind of
say, okay, cut your losses.
Yeah, fine, great bosses.
So I opened up your book,
I'm on an airplane and I
think it was in the forward,
but I was reading that what I really
love about it is it's designed to,
you can read any chapter, you don't have
to go chapter one, two, three, four, five.
Um, and I think that's a
really unique approach.
And I went straight to the table of
contents and was looking at like, hmm.
Like what do I want to
start with your first, um,
wanted to ask you why you made that choice
and if that was based on some of your
interviews with people that you
met with, um, based on, you know,
what books are available
in the marketplace and how
they're structured, um,
or what led you to make that decision?
Um,
the,
the simple answer is I did structure
it in a way that I thought,
uh, people on average
would evolve. However, uh,
you're going to be only interested
in the challenge that you're facing.
So you should start with that challenge
and get into it and see if you can get
value from it. Um, I, uh,
enjoyed all the chapters and I spent
a lot of time thinking about where,
where they should go. So
it turns out that, uh,
there are a couple of basic
themes in the book. Uh,
one is about fear and that's,
uh, shows up in pressure,
it shows up in superheroes, uh, and uh,
it shows up and taking risk or
speaking up, daring to challenge.
Another one is caring,
meaning purpose that shows up in
the first and the last chapter, uh,
and feeling purposeful. And then
there's a third theme around people.
And so, uh, I put all those guys
together, bringing people on board,
even when you just like,
wish you could just tell him what to do
and make them do it and they just won't
do it. Uh, or working with creeps or, uh,
or trying to get a sponsor. So
those, those kind of fit together.
But you're going to have the best
experience of the book if you start with
what's what matters to
you. Thank you. All right,
time for Tim or questions.
I know we're running a little
over for folks that have to leave.
Hi. So I guess after listening to you,
I fall in the millennial category.
I thought it was a gen x, um, that
I have noticed I'm a millennial too,
even though I'm an old one
and it's something I've
noticed in train and network
or new conversations
is that often it's really hard to get
on the connecting side with people as
often. I find that because of
whatever perceptions they have,
they want to other you instead.
And so I know that listening to them is
a good strategy to try and bring them
back, but it's always like, how
do you get to that listening side?
Like how you ask questions that will
help open them up or what are things that
you can,
strategies that you can do,
like getting to that part or in that
process to kind of maybe open them up,
maybe bring them back. That's a
really good question. So there's,
there's a couple of things for
you to think about. What is,
who do you admire and as you
reach out to people you admire,
actually tell them why you admire them
specifically, not generically. Uh,
there was a woman in the book whose
name is now escaping me, jet lag,
let's blame it on that or
my age. But anyway, she, uh,
she always starts with specific praise
that is genuine and people love to hear
about themselves.
So if you start with that,
you've now opened them up and then ask
a question of what's important to you.
For example,
Amy is an extraordinary marketer and
you tell her that and then you say,
I would really like to learn more about
the skills that you developed early on.
Is there a way that I could,
without taking any of your time
learn from you? And she might say,
just walk with me here or just come to
this meeting with me that, so there,
there is that sort of, that way of
saying don't. Um, instead of saying,
will you be my mentor? Which the
only answer is no because I'm really,
I'm a re everybody is really busy.
But to say,
could I just, you know, walk
with you down in the elevator.
I have one question for you.
That's one way to do it and you've got
to have the questions that matter to you
that you think will better to that person.
The other thing that Sheryl taught me,
uh,
and we've interacted now since 2013
because of our shared passion for women is
a, the offer to help has to be specific.
So you might say as a younger person,
and I really want to help you and that's,
that's a burden.
So you think about I by helping you,
what I'd like to do for you is,
uh,
look at all the research that we have
access to and then I'm going to call Carla
correlated for you or do something.
So the specific help that you offer,
then I could just say yes or no. I
could probably would say, oh my God,
you're such a doll.
Would you please do that for me?
That was how I ended up becoming
better friends with Eileen.
And the early days when she was starting
women out here in New York. And I said,
well, let me just comment. I'll take notes
and follow through on the action items.
And she was like,
great.
But it was an exam very specific
with how I could help, um,
with something that was important to her.
But very tactical and specific.
So last question, or we have to, we,
you guys want to fire them away.
I wanted to ask about the slide where
you had perceptions of new leaders,
the to old leaders and what you think
will prevent the new leaders from ending
up like the old leaders.
Do you think that it's the company's
culture or something with millennials that
will end up changing
things for the future?
Or will we sort of see how things
are happening from the old leader's
perspective and say,
we've got to get in line.
So there's this psychological
research that was done on monkeys. Um,
and it was, I'm trying to remember,
I think Adam Grant wrote it up, uh,
in the book option B, but Oh,
Mckenzie uses it a lot as well.
So this is notion that there are a bunch
of monkeys. They're in a a pen and they,
there's a beautiful bunch of bananas up
these stairs and the first monkey goes
up to get it and he gets doused with,
you know,
water like really horrible hose.
He falls down.
So the second monkey goes, I can do
better. I can do this. It goes up water.
Third Monkey.
After a while the monkeys stop going up
the ladder to get the bananas because
they know what's coming.
The monkeys died sad,
but it happens. They take the monkey
out, they put a new monkey in.
The monkey doesn't go up the ladder,
the new monkey.
And why is that happening?
Because the older monkeys are saying,
you go up the ladder,
you're going to get like shot with water.
It's a horrible experience.
Don't do it.
Now obviously they do that and
monkey talk, but they figure out,
they literally hold that young monkey
from doing that thing. That's my fear.
My fear is that cultures tend
to show us how to be successful.
And the people,
the young people who are the most
successful in the cultures definition will
mold to look like the leaders.
And this is one of the many,
many reasons why it's harder for women
than men because men are more capable of
mirroring the man at
the top that they see.
It's much harder for women to do that.
The second thing that happens
to people as you get successful,
so you're a young person
and you're getting success
in this formula that you're
you, that you didn't even know you have,
but it becomes a formula pretty quickly.
And then you just repeat it.
And as you are successful,
your mind starts to shut down. You
like, I'm successful doing this,
this is efficient. I'm going to do it
again. I'm going to do it again and again.
Make all this money and be famous
and all those things. And um,
you close yourself down.
And so one of the things I
noticed when I interviewed older,
very successful leaders is they
weren't that curious. They had it,
they knew the story, they delivered
the story and they were done. Um,
so those are the two like giant rocks
that are threatening to crush you as you
go through the ladder.
And I think what you could
do to avoid it is one,
as a community shifts the culture,
which can actually be done pretty quickly.
The leaders have to want to do it,
they have to role model it. And the
second is to ask yourself all the time,
what can I learn here? She just
start with that. I'm successful.
What can I learn here?
It'll help.
I learned a lot. Um, I always
did from your Joanna. Okay,
I'll be here. Uh, wonderful.
Uh, thank you for joining us.
Stay curious. And, uh, we will, uh,
do our best to grow and continue to
grow while we work here at Google.
So everybody thinks,
okay.